demandez des montages plus serein et
plus rapide je vous donne 5 astuces pour
ça et salut à tous ses amis c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore et vous avez été très nombreux à
me demander de nouveaux tuto sur le
montage vidéo
donc aujourd'hui je vous donne 5 astuces
que j'utilise moi même sur à peu près
tous les montages et oui je te connais
toi qui es pressé de voir ce côté plan
données qui va des roches est vite fait
et puis pourquoi pas appliquer quelques
petits effets histoire de voir ce que ça
va donner
tu te stop de suite non tu te stop des
trucs qui vont vous permettre de gagner
du temps d'être plus tranquille par
rapport à vos fichiers est globalement
d'aller un petit peu plus vite ils vous
qu'un petit peu de temps perdu au début
pour les préparatifs pour bien se lancer
pour être tranquille après ça peut être
beaucoup temps de gagner par la suite
alors comme d'habitude ce que je vous
montre ses sur final cut mais sachez que
sur première lien exactement les mêmes
fonctionnalités c'est juste ficher un
petit peu différemment et entendu il ya
d'autres façons de faire qui peuvent
selon les projets beaucoup plus
pertinente aller sans plus attendre ces
partis attaquons nous aux premiers
points c'est-à-dire le stockage alors
mon premier conseil en fonction de votre
machine bien sûr parce que si vous avez
une tour pc avec des disques durs très
très gros et plein de disques durs ça va
pas forcément s'appliquer encore que
c'est de monter sur le disque externe
alors pour ça il existe plusieurs
solutions
on va un petit peu les compas première
solution c'est le disque à plateau
classique a pour avantage de fournir
beaucoup d espace pour un prix qui est
quand même relativement abordable
l'inconvénient c'est qu'on va avoir un
disque et qui va être peu rapide et si
on monte des fichiers en très haute
résolution comme de la 4k on risque
d'avoir des petits soucis avec en plus
de ça ça peut tomber ça peut se casser
donc c'est pas cher et c'est idéal pour
démarrer mais ce n'est pas la solution
la plus optimale dans l'autre extrême on
a des solutions plus professionnelle
c'est-à-dire les systèmes raid qui vont
être plusieurs disques montés en série
qui vont être plus rapide qui vont
pouvoir se copier les ans les autres
dont on aura une sécurité si jamais on a
un disque qui claquent les inconvénients
c'est que ce sont des systèmes qui sont
quand même relativement cher et qui ne
sont absolument pas portable c'est
quelque chose que vous n'avez pas
pouvoir amener avec vous facilement pour
monter dans le train ou en mobilité
dernière solution celle que moi
j'utilise ce sont les ssd l'avantagé
c'est que ce sont des disques qui sont
très rapides donc qui permettent des
débits en écriture
la turquie sont très élevés qui sont un
petit peu moins fragile que les disques
durs à plateaux et surtout qu'on peut
les transporter un petit peu partout
donc en mobilité
c'est vachement bien mais dans tous les
cas moi je vous recommande fortement de
stocker vos rush sur des disques
externes tout simplement parce que
monter de la vidéo quand on a des
fichiers de rendu et c'est ça prend
beaucoup de place et si vous ne voulez
pas avoir à faire des trans vasa jeu pas
si ce mot existe mais à transvaser vos
fichiers de votre ordinateur sur un
disque plus du disque sur l'ordinateur
etc
moi je suggère cette solution-là de
monter directement sur des disques
externes
et puis en débit histoire d'être
tranquille partait sur de l'usb 3
minimum passons maintenant au deuxième
point il s'agit de l'import de ces
fichiers alors maintenant qu'on a décidé
où il fallait y stocker nos fichiers
vidéo on va s'intéresser à comment les
importer parce que là aussi pour pas
faire n'importe quoi alors on va ouvrir
notre carte sd on va les sélectionner le
dossier dans lequel se trouve noureuil
puis sur notre disque dur on va créer un
dossier que moi j'ai appelé explique
nous encore mais que vous appellerez
comme vous voudrez en fonction du projet
est dedans on va pouvoir créer des
dossiers en fonction des différents
appareils que vous utilisez si vous en
utilisez plusieurs lames ont par exemple
j'ai mis le 6 des le à 7 la gopro et un
dossier aussi pour l'audio pour la voie
que je capte séparément les musiques et
éventuellement des effets sonores
maintenant jour mon dossier ici je fais
glisser mes éléments est terminée on ne
parle plus c'est importer une petite
astuce s'il ya des fichiers que vous
utiliser de façon récurrente dans nos
vidéos comme des génériques comme des
musiques qui reviennent systématiquement
des images
n'hésitez pas à les stocker sur votre
ordinateur cela puisque ils vont être
récurrent vous avez utilisé souvent donc
vous savez où ils sont sur votre
ordinateur et ça évitera de les copier à
chaque fois dans les dossiers qu'on va
utiliser pour le montage déjà on va
commencer par nous mais notre projet
ensuite on va cliquer sur le bouton d'un
port et là on va pas faire l'erreur
d'aller chercher sur la carte sd 1 parce
qu'on aura pu l'enlever déjà entre temps
puisqu'on aura déjà importé noureuil on
va aller sur le disque dur qui contient
louret ch
on sélectionne noureuil
on vérifie que on va les importer dans
le bon événement on va bien sélectionner
conserver les fichiers à leur place ça
évitera de les avoir un double en ça
sert à rien de les importer deux fois et
on va cochet créer un média proxy ça je
vous explique à quoi ça sert dans le
point sur et pour finir on n'a plus qu'à
cliquer sur le bouton importer la
sélection ça y est on a importé nos
fichiers s'est pas encore tout à fait
fini maintenant on va s'intéresser aux
fichiers proxy alors qu'est ce qu'un
fichier proxy vous allez me dire ça fait
un petit peu technique ça fait un petit
peu compliqué pas du tout un fichier
proxy c'est tout simplement un pichet
qui va être générée par votre logiciel
et qui va être en basse résolution par
rapport à votre fichier original
alors vous allez me dire moi je ne fais
pas chier à filmer en 4k pour avoir des
fichiers basse résolution
non y'a pas de soucis vous inquiétez pas
ces fichiers proxy ils vont servir
uniquement pour le montage sur votre
timeline pour alléger un petit peu la
tâche de l'ordinateur et faire en sorte
que ce soit plus facilement montables
team moins de calcul que ce soit moins
lourd mais à l'export ce sont bien les
fichiers originaux 4k ou full hd qui
seront utilisés par ordinateur pour le
montage final
et c'est donc un gros avantage
d'utiliser ces fichiers proxy puisque
même si vous avez des fichiers qui sont
très lourds 4k etc
vous allez pouvoir faire du montage même
si votre machine n'est pas une bête de
course puisque elle utilisera les
fichiers proxy pour le montage ça va pas
ramener ça va pas la gay dans tous les
sens ont par contre à deux tout petits
inconvénients
le premier c'est qu'il va falloir
attendre que ces fichiers soient générés
bon c'est pas très long an soit 1 mais
quand même attendre un petit peu même si
on peut commencer avec les fichiers
originaux et là on perd tout l'intérêt
d'avoir des proxy et ça n'enlève pas le
fait qu'au final les bains l'ordinateur
va quand même devoir traiter les
fichiers originaux pour faire l'export
de votre vidéo et donc forcément si vous
avez monté des très gros fichiers ça
prendra du temps pour l'expo passons
maintenant à la 4è astuces je veux bien
sûr parler d kalck d
alors les quelques effets et j'ai fait
une vidéo complète sur le sujet que vous
pouvez aller voir en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche ici sur votre écran
donc je vais pas détailler ici ce qu'est
le quelques des faits grosso modo ça
consiste à mettre un calque sur tout
votre vidéo ou sur plusieurs parties si
vous voulez changer un petit peu les
effets entre les différentes parties
mais ça va vous permettre de gérer les
effets de façon beaucoup plus simple et
beaucoup plus sereine est beaucoup plus
équilibré par contre on fera
l'étalonnage des rushes directement sur
les vidéos et pas sur lequel que des
faits mais ça je vous ferai une vidéo
sur le sujet très bien enfin cinquième
et dernière astuce je vais vous parler
des groupes de plans alors les groupes
de blanc c'est une fonctionnalité très
utile surtout si comme moi vous
enregistrer l'audio séparément de la
vidéo que ça va vous permettre comme son
nom l'indiqué de groupe et les plans et
de pouvoir les traiter ensemble sans
avoir à les dissocier
alors les plans groupés c'est vraiment
pas compliqué on va juste sélectionné le
plan vidéo et le plan audio alors on
s'assurera d'abord avant de les
sélectionner qui sont bien calés l'un
par rapport à l'autre et qui sont bien
synchro ensuite je vais faire un petit
halte j'ai donné un nom à mon plan là je
l'appelle face cam 1 puis seulement
peut-être plusieurs jeux cliquer sur ok
et je n'ai plus qu'un seul plan et si je
double cliquer dessus
je vais quand même pouvoir avoir accès à
mes fichiers d'origine c'est à dire je
pouvoir traiter le son je vais pouvoir
traiter l'image et même si j'ai découpé
comme ici différents plans et ben je
peux quand même appliquer un traitement
à l'image globale à tous montrouge de
départ ou à tout le monde ce sont deux
départs et voilà les amis c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura été utile qu'elle vous
aura plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
mettre le traditionnel coup de blaster
sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe en
dessous de cette vidéo ainsi que sur le
bouton s'abonner sur la cloche tout ça
tout ça j'ai fait un petit sondage
auprès de vous il ya quelques temps par
rapport au contenu de la chaîne si vous
préfériez les analyses de série fille ou
les tutos est grosso modo c'était un
petit peu kifkif donc bah je vais
alterner entre les deux vous inquiétez
pas il y aura encore des analyses de
série il y aura encore des tutos encore
merci de votre fidélité
je vois vos commentaires en dessous
j'essaie de répondre à absolument tous
les commentaires ça fait chaud au coeur
à la plupart
vraiment des messages qui encourage qui
font très plaisir je tenais à vous le
dire dans cette nouvelle vidéo
en attendant comme d'habitude mais je
sais que vous le faites déjà rester
curieux et moi je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]
prix